una construcción que refleja
desconfianza todavía con el temor de
haber sido invadida por la unión
soviética durante la Segunda Guerra
Mundial Finlandia lleva adelante el
levantamiento de una valla que le
brindará protección en su frontera con
Rusia
la necesidad fue provocada por un cambio
en la situación de seguridad en Europa
el mayor cambio que ha ocurrido En
nuestro tiempo la situación en la
frontera Oriental ha sido y sigue siendo
estableado
en el pasado la región donde hoy se
ubica el cruce fronterizo de raya josepy
recibió una inversión de millones de
euros para favorecer el paso entre Rusia
y Finlandia pero el tránsito ha
disminuido desde 2014 tras la anexión
rusa de crimea y ahora por la guerra los
finlandeses respaldan la iniciativa de
un muro Más allá de la protección del
territorio como medida para el control
de la migración
Esta es la única forma efectiva y segura
de controlar la entrada a gran escala
la experiencia de Polonia y los países
bálticos con su frontera con belarus lo
demuestras
creo que es algo muy bueno hubiese sido
mejor haberla construido hace mucho
tiempo
otros por su parte no están de acuerdo
con el proyecto
personalmente no creo que sea muy
necesario pero ciertamente como ha
causado mucho miedo la situación mucha
gente siente que es importante
Finlandia y Rusia comparten una frontera
de 1.340 kilómetros de extensión la más
larga entre un país de la Unión Europea
y Rusia se espera que la nueva valla
cubra unos 200 km y se ubica en las
partes consideradas como las más
críticas de la zona limítrofe